hey guys what's up Austin all of the
nine Knowles here numidia rock stars pay
me a ridiculous amount of money to come
talk to Olga Kay and some of her YouTube
friends about her new moosh walk socks
these are them joining me via satellite
is exquisite sought correspondent
audreanna
okay Wow Audrey what are you most
looking forward to tonight wah wah wah
I'm excited as well anyways let's get
this party started
what was the inspiration for all of it
well I I'm upset with knee-high socks I
wear them with everything in my life I
always wanted to create something like
this and i knew i had to create
something different i really like the
ears these are like super sexy socks
baba o apples I emailed my designer who
was a girl who used to watch my videos
and shoes to draw me with my dog all the
time and said hey can you create like a
really cool suck design no Maddie um
when Olga came to you with this idea
what was your thoughts on this whole
thing um well actually I thought it was
dumb
I know this isn't gonna be the best
thing ever now that we've got everything
going it's just so cool it's ridiculous
if they're so awesome i love them so
much i'm here with Jack Douglas of Jack
films how's it going man oh just loving
life man having a good time at olga's
moosh party yeah now this is a red
carpet so what are you wearing okay
target and walmart right and mainly your
socks what what kind of socks oh they're
um they're their whites I'm wearing
actually just plain white socks I'm just
wearing the old playing gray socks today
I haven't gotten new sauce since eighth
grade I'm wearing oh the case ox moose
walks by olga kay yeah and this is
actually her dress that's was really i'm
wearing old ahead
just looking ahead how do you think your
life is gonna change once you put these
moosh walks on what isn't going to
change is the better question I think
it's gonna be just endless amounts of
chicks whenever I want snap my fingers
and they're right there going on long
walks on the beach obviously there's
gonna be a lot more sensual the the
women are gonna come up and be like whoa
buddy easy there I'm looking forward to
playing footsie with to nose oh it could
be you you never know be anyone
wah wah wah I'm feeling much more peppy
fun energetic you know the world is a
better place when you wear wish walks
really wrong my mouth alright guys once
again I'm Austin ole that's it for us
tonight I'm gonna go collect my
ginormous paycheck from new media rock
stars so I'll see you guys on my yacht
thanks for watching as always I don't
forget to subscribe now new media
rockstars told me they will kidnap one
of my children should you not subscribe
I'm just saying the fate of one of my
children may be in your hands so go
ahead and subscribe and we'll see as
always don't forget to like this video
share it on Twitter and Facebook and all
the other social medias there's a lot of
them nowadays and we'll talk to you
later